martial foucault bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être sur ce plateau directeur
du cevipof centre de recherches
politiques de sciences po emmanuel
macron marine le pen c'était le duel
annoncé par les instituts de sondages
ces dernières semaines ça ne veut pas
dire que les résultats de ce premier
tour ne sont pas surprenants oui il faut
pas les lire à l'aune de ce que on avait
découvert en 2000 en 2017 parce que
finalement on remarque une
transformation quand même assez
puissante dans le paysage politique on
est passé d'une situation de quatre
grands blocs en 2017 à trois blocs alors
quel est le bloc mans caen bc leblanc
que le bloc de la droite républicaine
donc après le ps ait l'air est
totalement la mine est aujourd'hui en
france donc une partie de ses électeurs
ont comme massivement voter utile je
trouve que le score de valérie pécresse
-2 5% veut dire que une partie des
électeurs compatible avec emmanuel
macron ont rejoint dès le premier tour
emmanuel macron ce qui va poser un
problème pour le président de la
république d'avoir des réserves de voix
pour progresser et anglais enclencher
une dynamique de campagne et puis l
inverse pour tous les partis on va dire
de gouvernement
socialo écologique aux démocrates le
nombre d'électeurs est très très faible
et donc pour réveiller le maquereau va
se poser une vraie question comment
convaincre ses électeurs comment
convaincre leurs responsables de partis
aussi de faire indirectement campagne
pour faire barrage à marine le pen au
second tour d'autant qu'on imagine mal
certains reports de voix par exemple
quand on va jean luc mélenchon qui fait
dans les 20% il appelle à faire barrage
à marine le pen il n'empêche qu'on
imagine mal beaucoup d'électeurs de jean
luc mélenchon se tourner non vous avez
raison mais j'ai trouvé que le discours
hier de jean luc mélenchon était quand
même beaucoup plus claire des de celui
d'il ya cinq ans où la déception était
grande et l'avait conduit à être
extrêmement ambigu sur la pause sa
position et la position qui le donné
comme consigne de voir ses électeurs
hier soir c'est beaucoup plus clair mais
en même temps pendant cinq ans
macron a été la cible de tous les
reproches de la politique des mails
macron par le leader de la france
insoumise et ça marque les esprits on
veut pas pendant cinq ans taper fort
contre président la république et en
deux semaines convertir ses électeurs et
je pense que le vrai risque pourrait mal
macron au fond c'est un peu le piège qui
se refermerait sur lui-même sert le
piège d'un clivage qu'il a lui-même
installer les progressistes contre les
populistes et pendant ces deux semaines
on peut voir émerger une forme de deux
coalitions sur le mode non pas des
lecteurs qui se reconnaîtrait
socialement mais à un mode du
ressentiment le poids des émotions des
coalitions affective anti macron un
petit peu comme en 2012 le tout sauf
sarkozy est bien pour cet entre deux
tours il ya un risque pour les maillots
mâcon c'est qu'il est une coalition
contre sa politique sur un mode encore
j'insiste vraiment des affects qui vont
jouer beaucoup pendant cet entre deux
tours d'autant qu'il faut pas oublier
qu'elle mouvement des gilets jaunes amis
et aussi un grand mécontentement aussi
dû rendre à la crise sanitaire et tout
cela a cristallisé les frustrations
oui oui c'est effectivement c'est la
lecture qu'on doit avoir ses raisons
c'est à dire que pendant pendant ces
cinq ans se sont accumulés des rancoeurs
se sont accumulés des colères lors des
colères sociales et colère politiques
parfois des colères morale même sur la
manière dont emmanuel macron incarner la
fonction présidentielle et comment ils
s'adressaient où s'adresser mal à
l'ensemble des français donc oui
aujourd'hui marine le pen va
certainement dans cet entre-deux-tours
jouer à essayer de sédimenter l'ensemble
de ses colères quand bien même les
français qui l'ont qui ont voté pour
elle au premier tour il va falloir être
très prudent et les analyses sont pas
des français qui partagent une vision la
même vision de la france pour les
prochaines années martial foucault vous
restez avec nous on va continuer bien
sûr à analyser ses résultats dans les
tailles trouve à nouveau martial
foucault directeur du cevipof merci
d'être avec nous c'est la grande
différence par rapport à l'élection
présidentielle précédente c'est que la
marine le pen bénéficie d'une réserve de
voix concrète avec eric zemmour wind
réserve plus grande qu'en 2017
je dois dire que le rôle que va jouer
jean luc mélenchon malgré son discours
d'hier soir va être décisif parce que le
dés qu'on ne peut pas se faire sans le
report des voix des électeurs de jean
luc mélenchon aujourd'hui on a des
éléments qui permettent de dire on est
autour de un tiers un tiers un tiers un
tiers l'abstention un tiers jean du pin
un tiers emmanuel macron et un tiers
marine le pen même ce tiers pour les
deux candidats ne suffira pas donc ça
veut dire que pendant cet entre deux
tours c'est une nouvelle campagne qui
démarre chacun des protagonistes doit
choisir un thème capable de parler aux
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon et on
voit là la l'impossibilité pour et
marine le pen et emmanuel macron de
choisir une thématique qui jédir
facilitera ne posera aucune question aux
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon pour
rejoindre l'un des deux camps dès hier
soir
marine le pen a attaqué cette campagne
de second tour elle a reparlé de son
thème phare le pouvoir d'achat une
campagne très axé sur le social s'est
aussi d'une certaine façon faire
campagne sur le social - parler d'un
volet sacrément plus clivants de son
disque de son programme qui est celui de
l'immigration oui ça c'est le rôle que
va jouer certainement eric zemmour dans
l'entre-deux-tours d'ailleurs ce qui
n'est pas sans poser problème sur la
difficulté pour marine le pen de
contrôle est en quelque sorte les
sorties d'eric zemmour pendant pendant
les deux prochaines semaines sur une
thématique qui est la thématique de
l'immigration et la thématique de
l'insécurité
pour marine le pen je rappellerai un
point parce que je crois qu'il est
décisif pour comprendre ce qui s'est
passé dans cette campagne ça a été la
première candidate dès le mois de
septembre 2021 a installé la question du
pouvoir d'achat la question des petits
salaires comme elle le disait et elle a
tenu avec peut-être un coup d'avancé par
rapport à l'ensemble de ses adversaires
cette question du social ce qui lui
permettra probablement par rapport à
2010 est d'être moins attaqué sur un
procès d' incompétent sur les questions
économiques qui avaient été l'enjeu du
duel télévisé de l'entré deux tours pas
on n'est pas dans la tête d'emmanuel
macro mais qu'est ce qu'elle dit qu en
côte qu'est-ce qu'il dit quand il se dit
prêt à inventer quelque chose de nouveau
pour rassembler les convictions et des
sensibilités diverses le côté nouveau
produit c'était il ya cinq ans oui c'est
une formule qui elle mérite d'être très
consensuel maintenant on demande d'avoir
qu'est ce qui va se produire dans les
prochains jours je crois qu'il a compris
qu'il fallait qu'il fasse campagne est
une campagne de terrain donc ça c'est
une certaine manière c'est un peu la
vieille politique b c'est celle qui
permet dans un entre-deux tours de
d'aller chercher des électeurs parce que
on a peu parlé de l'abstention mais il
ya aussi à une réserve de voix très
importante parmi les abstentionnistes
qui considérait que attendons de voir le
premier tour pour pouvoir prendre une
position une position soit républicaine
anti marine le pen ou une position
beaucoup plus anti macron dans cet entre
deux tours est ce que ça va faire une
campagne à gauche mais qui sort
peut-être avec une jambe droite un peu
plus renforcé de ce scrutin
s'il veut effectivement séduire les
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon il va
falloir qu'il ait des signes assez assez
fort à l'endroit de cet électorat je
pense pas que cela le conduirait à
revenir sur deux trois marqueurs de sa
campagne jusqu'à présent la question de
la retraite à 65 ans la question de la
conditionnalité du rsa ou encore cette
question de cette grande réforme de
l'allocation chômage or ce sont des
éléments qui du point de vue de jean luc
mélenchon sont sont quasiment non
négociable pour obtenir en tout cas sa
voix et les voix des militants la france
est soumise mais là si on y revient dans
le détail dans l'info aequo avec lille
rifaï merci beaucoup martial foucault
mais vous restez avec nous foucault
rebonjour directeur du cevipof centre de
recherches politiques de sciences po
c'est la troisième fois dans l'histoire
de la vème que l'extrême droite se
qualifierait pour le second tour de la
présidentielle mais elle n'a jamais été
aussi proches qu'en 2022 d'accéder pour
le coup on pourra oui troisième fois sur
au cours des cinq dernières élections
présidentielles donc d'une certaine
manière le rendez-vous est en train de
s'installer pour pour pour l'extrême
droite jamais aussi proche probablement
compte tenu de la configuration du du
premier tour contrairement à 2002 2010
est cette fois-ci marine le pen peut
compter sur un jeudi pas un très grand
réservoir de votes mais il ya un certain
nombre de devoirs on va dire à peu près
10% de l'électorat qui s'est exprimé au
premier tour qui pourrait vous joins
assez aisément marine le pen maintenant
il reste à marine le pen a non seulement
à convaincre cet électorat que elle est
la candidate capable de renverser la
table
avec une situation assez paradoxale
puisque les partis traditionnels sont
écartés sont à des niveaux
historiquement bas et au fond le
rassemblement de national devient le
parti traditionnel de cette 5ème
république installé depuis plus de 40
ans et donc ça aussi c'est un élément
qu'elle va devoir à la fois assumer et
expliqué qu' elle n'a pas la même
pratique du pouvoir politique la même
pratique de l'exercice d'un pouvoir au
cours des prochaines années donc c'est
un jeu assez délicat elle même
d'incarner le nouveau où l'opposition
tout en étant la figure d'une
organisation qui est présente depuis
très longtemps par rapport à ses
adversaires et en faisant campagne
notamment sur le pouvoir d'achat le
social l'insécurité l'immigration une
quelles peuvent être les thèmes de
campagne que peut lancer face à elle et
emmanuel macron alors certainement pas
ce que vous venez d'évoquer parce que
aujourd'hui marine le pen on dit dans
notre jargon elle est la propriété de
cet enjeu donc elle a une sorte de
légitimité à avoir installé et d'avoir
réussi à convaincre beaucoup d'électeurs
avec des jets à des motivations du vote
sur sa candidature très différents pour
emmanuel macron moi je vois un enjeu
celui qui permettra d'envoyer un message
de faire un pas vers vers la gauche de
jean luc mélenchon mais aussi faut pas
oublier la gauche écologique et la
gauche socialiste et je crois que cet
enjeu de l'écologie de l'environnement
qui a été une certaine manière un rendez
vous manqué durant ce quinquennat pour
emmanuel macron sera une thématique qui
peut lui donne à la fois une crédibilité
et concourir à ce que les électeurs
reconnaissent dans emmanuel macron cette
possibilité de s'attaquer à une des
préoccupations majeures rapport du giec
la semaine passée et pour lesquels m
marine le pen n'est pas perçu comme
étant la candidate la plus crédible pour
se saisir de l'enjeu environnemental
avec en deux mois un risque très
important de celui du procès en
opportunisme politique d'autant plus que
ce sujet est loin d'être en tout cas
pour les électeurs de jean luc mélenchon
une
quelque chose qu'on sort du chapeau pour
la pour la porte le manteau oui alors
c'est peut-être là où il faut deviner le
en creux la phrase est venue elle m'a
confié hier soir quand il a dit qu'il
fallait faire quelque chose de nouveau
je pense qu'il va être attendu je pense
que tous les jours les journalistes vont
l'interroger sur quel est ce nouveau qui
apparaît dans cette campagne d'entre
deux tours merci marcel vous quand vous
restez avec nous parmi les surprises de
ce scrutin qu'on sentait venir depuis
quelques semaines il y a il ya ce
chiffre damien oui environ 7% des voix
eric zemmour ne provoque pas le séisme
électoral qu'il escomptait si le
polémiste l extrême droite reconnaît des
désaccords avec marine le pen hier soir
il a tout de même appelé à voter pour
elle au second tour retour sur un pari
raté avec christophe d'ancêtres
il rêvait d'une reconquête
eric zemmour manque son pari seule
consolation il arrive devant valérie
pécresse
tout le monde comprendra que nos idées
valent beaucoup plus que notre score
d'aujourd'hui
je n'ai pas su convaincre assez de nos
compatriotes l'histoire dira et dira
pourquoi nous ne sommes pas parvenus
alors qu'une majorité de français
partage nos inquiétudes et nos espoirs
désespoir porté très haut lorsque les
sondages de données jusqu'à 17% au
premier tour
phénomène du début de campagne l'ancien
polémiste et des portés par des scores
d'audience record une grande ferveur
dans les meetings un certain nombre de
têtes d'affiché du rassemblement
national avait rejoint son mouvement
mais la bulle a fini par éclater eric
zemmour est largement distancé par
marine le pen pour qui il appelle à
voter au deuxième tour ces militants ne
cachent pas leur déception on pense
avoir plus on va pas se mentir c'est le
début d'une nouvelle aventure fossard
trop conquête c'est tout nouveau
il ya un an ça n'existait même pas on ne
savait même pas en fait qu'un tel
mouvement patriote allait émerger en
france donc voilà
un peu d'amertume et laissé plus le
début d'un long chemin une longue
bataille une longue bataille qui
continuera avec les législatives eric
zemmour espère pouvoir remporter
plusieurs sièges lui même pourraient se
présenter dans le sud de la france
marcel foucault au risque de le
retrouver encore sur la scène politique
française eric zemmour oui mais
peut-être pas nécessairement comme comme
parlementaire comme député élu je crois
que eric zemmour a déjà acquis cette
stature nationale est-ce qu'il a besoin
d'une tribune offerte par parlement j'en
suis pas certain et ensuite c'est une
organisation politique à construire et
sa jeu on n'a pas d'élément qui permette
de dire que eric zemmour a envie d'être
un chef de parti pascal et d'organiser
dans deux mois voilà législatives et
préparer on sait que la vie d'un parti
passe aussi par une forme de maillage
territorial et ça je crois que c'est pas
du tout l'ambition d'eric zemmour pour
le moment attendons de voir le résultat
du second tour parce que il y aura
peut-être un enjeu de succession des
droites extrêmes si marine le pen était
battu dans deux semaines